bonjour à tous alors on continue avec
notre découverte des parties dali keane
est bon en retour en 1908 toujours le
même temps a donc de moscou automne à
moscou et
les kinés encore les blancs il affronte
un joueur s'appelle rozanoff vasti
heroes à neuf et 4 je vous promets
groupe air liquide
son adversaire le joug b6 donc ouverte
sur peut jouer mais ma foi pourquoi pas
un viol c'est le fond bissett
l'ouverture qu'on appelle au one
du coup des 4 prend le centre fou
bessette qui a laissé 3 6 et kf3
nouvelle fois développement très très
classique de la part d' alexander a li
qin kai et 3 très bien là avec les noms
il a joué des cinq je pense c'est déjà
un poil douteux même si déjà l'ouverture
en soi est pas terrible je veux dire ce
v6 machin bon c'est jouable peut être
occasionnellement mais c'est pas fou
mais il faudrait au moins continuer par
poule b 4 ici l'idée c'est de pas
enfermer le fou avec des cinq tout cas
pas maintenant mais donc de faire
flamber 4 pourquoi pour clouer le
cavalier et au passage donc on attaquera
le pion de 4 et parme sur foot roi on
pourrait faire un peu le même genre
d'idée on aimerait bien que les blancs
face au 5e même pourquoi pas absolument
de calais dix ans assure une bonne case
ici et le fou célébrer sa diagonale
et voilà et donc en général ici si les
blancs d' défendent défendent avec dame
eu deux bons toujours pareil pour
défendre le pion le pion ici à ce moment
pourrait faire des 5 et sur cinq mètres
lecavalier en le 4 maintenant voilà ça
ça ça existe c'est jouable via d'autres
systèmes n'est sûr pour les blancs c'est
pas c'est pas le souci mais juste pour
dire voilà éventuellement fou b4 mieux
que des 5 parce que les kin va très bien
réagir sur des 5
j'aime beaucoup le groupe qu'il a joué
c'est fou b5 échec est en fait ouais
c'est hyper bien mais en fait il vient
peut réfuter l'idée des noirs du fian de
kétou puisqu'il provoque le coup ces 6es
il dit ouais bah bravo des arbitres ont
fondé cette d'avoir joué b6 foulée 7
pour te mettre un trou devant loeb voilà
tu avais une belle vue vue mer bon bah
là tu viens de te construire un immeuble
un deuxième immeuble où ma tu as vu
souterrain maintenant bon voilà ouais
c'est pour ça que c'est ça que j'aime
bien le vrai me prendre soin coup comme
cas et 17 qui par l échec 1 vous comme
kallio 5 très pénibles parce que on
vient renforcer le clouage cavalli et 6
par exemple un moyen simple geste
reprend 2 prend des fous g5 ont tous
cavaliers ont coup suis là et les
normandes perte du matériel ainsi sa
maman sous peu donc on peut comprendre
après fou b5 que les noirs est jouée ces
six ok sûr que l'armée sont fondées 3
l'enjeu cali et 6 alors bon évidemment
on va perdre du temps à près de 5 un peu
comment les françaises mais c'est vrai
que prendre sa ressemblance rubinstein
de la française qui est pas très
réjouissantes pour les noirs avec sauce
et 6 mais bon peut-être que je comme ça
c'est plus solide avec l'invention tôt
ou tard de préparer ces cinq cars pas
trop vite mais de le faire à un moment
ou à un autre pour faire revivre ce chou
manière progressive peut-être
intéressant bon il a fait qu'ali et 6
est là avec les blancs il a plus de
taureau par les cornes les kin très bien
il a fait 1,5
walkyrie chez lui un peu calé 17 et cali
g5 bien joué bien jouer pourquoi parce
que attaque h7 bon aussi surtout libérer
le passage de la dame
pourquoi pas être 4 f 5 des choses comme
ça et il perd pas de temps pour aller
agresser les noirs qui sont déjà en
retard de développement
au passage or c'est le but c'est jamais
de faire des pièges en soi mais juste je
m'arrête pas ils l'auraient pas louper
suracheté s'il ya ça qui marche puis on
prend d'un match 5 recettes et déjà d'un
match 4 le truc c'est que si on voit ici
on se fait mater donc en fait ce qu'il
faut faire c'est rendre déjà une pièce
et avec le roi en cavale au milieu bon
ben ça se passe pas bien pour les noirs
quoi donc ouais je suis déjà va pas aux
fossettes et il a fait d'objets 4 donc
place la dame qui défendent cavaliers il
est prêt à bouger de cavaliers aller
taper g7 et ses accès
bon les noix elle essaie de mettre un
peu une formation carapace plus ou moins
effet kireev 8
et là il joue un coup ma foi assez
créatifs quoi les kin j'aime pas si
j'aurai spécialement vu quoi je vais
dire il a fait quel point c'est tout
- coût normal disons comme qui arrive
trois mois ça me serait venu plus
spontanément juste sauvant la dame pour
attaquer à gesat cinor voulait faire un
coup comme cahier j'ai six mois toujours
h4 idh 5 pour le dégager réitérer les
menaces et ont très très bien avec les
blancs mais quelle épreuve 7 c'est du
jeu direct alors l'idée c'est quoi sexy
et noir prennent du cavalier il veut
faire d'un projet cette attaque la tour
et attax aux cavaliers donc ça
clairement c'est très bien mais il a
pris de la tour vous prend qu'elle prend
d'un projet sap et qui allie fuite
hong kong où il a donné deux pièces un
trou un cavalier contre une tour et
compte deux pions mais son patron idée
c'est de dire oui mon très bien mais je
t'envoie le pion h
donc là en fait il ya triple idée en
fait quelque part avec ce coup h4 la
plus basique c'est de dire aux images
avions passé tarek qui l'empêchent je
fonce je vais faire une nouvelle dalle
bon clairement première idée
deuxième idée c'est d'activer ces deux
tours en voulant faire tout rage 3 et
pourquoi pas tous rêvent 3 par exemple
en deux coups on va on va directement
venir s'en prendre à af sept jeux
métrange le cas voilà et dernier arrivé
enfin c'est pourquoi pas garder l'option
de faire un coup comme plus g5 pour se
développer
voilà alors là dessus mais non en fait
on fait une erreur fatale
il a pris ce pion vous faites qui a
l'air très dangereux et c'est vrai qu'à
première lourde et tiens pourquoi pas
prendre
d'ailleurs vous pouvez mettre en pause
chercher d'autres côté pourquoi vous
prend h 4 c'est si mauvais c'est sympa
d'ailleurs sûrement que les noirs
devaient jouer c5 et je pense qu'un
joueur moderne le ferai plus volontiers
évidemment cherché contre jeu très vite
vite sortir le cavalier taper le centre
blanc affaiblir et faire un truc comme
ça quoi bon je pensais qu'elle serait
quand même pas mal avec un comme vous
j'ai 5
l'idée c'est qu'en cas de prison peut
prendre du pillon et voilà ça va libérer
la tour pour aller là-haut peut-être
faire g6 à un moment et ses racines
énorme prennent pas le truc c'est qu'on
m'a serait un petit et b5 qui elle est
si ce n'est que ce fou bas il peut plus
trop contre la casse des six comme il
serait cloué donc oui après tout les 5
vous reste quand même pas mal avec les
blancs mais au kenya parti kwa
apprennent francs h 4 juste a été finie
et elle et qui n'a pas loupé évidemment
donc j'espère que vous avez pris le
temps de chercher ce qu'ils voulaient et
j'espère retrouver pour vous me direz il
a fait naufrage quatre sacs de qualité
dame prend fou g5
mais c'est quoi l'idée en fait c'est
juste de prendre contrôle des canards et
faire d'un immeuble sis au prochain pour
pour venir ma télé noir quoi minutes
d'un machin échec
il a bougé droit bon au lieu d'un projet
de mai soit d'un prince était juste 2006
et matt imparable en fait là où là il ya
rien à faire pour les noirs
pas défendre les deux cases à la fois ci
le roi s'en va mende fait mater si
lecavalier vient défendre cette pensée
matin si lecavalier sort pour des formes
des huit bons c'est matt est ici donc
quoi qu'il en soit et des maths de
partout on ne peut pas défendre les
dolphin donc ouais bien joué de la part
des liquides avec les noirs bond a
appris j'ai deux bad à merci le même
problème juste au vent il s'est dit oui
bon moi je rends la dame mais si on fait
les comptes
en fait ils ont que deux pièces pour la
dame linars et ont quand même le roi
faibles ils ont quand même des problèmes
sur cases noires la tour à cannes
pouvoir s'activer rapidement pour entrer
l'art et essai des soucis donc là en
fait il a continué pour continuer on va
aller assez vite en fait parce que je
dois dire qu'il ya pas vraiment d'espoir
pour les noirs dans dans une telle
position
le roi est trop faible en fait pour que
deux pièces une chance contre la dame
faudrait être superbe coordination des
pièces est un peu un miracle mais une
dame dont prom de pièces trop forte
surtout avec un roi adverse si faible et
il le fait d'un projet 6 marrant pour en
finir donc les yeux abandon apparemment
bon l'idée savatier surprise prises on
va dire on va dire moi c'est cette ba je
sais pas il va peut-être sachant pas un
truc comme tanger 8 et vient taper le
pion les gagne petit à petit jordan
projet sis juste pas obligés du tout de
le faire je me demande même si ça auront
été joués c'est une fantaisie après
l'analyse
parce que y'a tellement de trucs plus
simple à faire ne serait-ce qu il prend
des cinq qui de découverte échec en
ramassant par un pion et c'est donc
voilà en tout cas très bonne partie dali
keane l'ouverture j'ai bien aimé le foot
et cinq échecs ici là c'est pas mal
c'est le genre d'idées qu'on va rentrer
retrouver après à travers l'histoire
alors pas forcément sur 4 b 6 mai dans
des west indienne bandits grünfeld pour
provoquer ces six prendre la case enfin
ce petit genre de coude et chaque pour
mieux repartir et gêner la coordination
des pièces adverse
voilà c'est déjà ses fins comme je vais
en fait et donc votre parti de talent et
qui en tout cas allez on se retrouve
pour un noël bientôt ciao ciao